we are talking about an article that is
primarily about youtube you are
justified in reaching out here because
you are mentioned in it but this is not
i am the title this is an article about
youtube policy
no this is an article about me in the
title be like saying oliver twist
mentions oliver
[Music]
hello hi i'm trying to reach uh jessica
cohen editor-in-chief at mashable
speaking oh hey jessica how are you this
is stephen crowder calling with comment
michael this is steven crowder calling
just with a comment uh
uh on an article that you recently uh
wrote about uh youtube remonetizing me
and
i assume that you guys reached out for a
comment and it must have gotten lost in
the mail
i'm sorry where where are you coming
from and this is my personal number
uh oh sorry this is sorry i apologize
so um you guys wrote an article uh about
me amanda yo
and you're listed as editor-in-chief
titled youtube re-monetizes stephen
crowder after suspension for racist
homophobic harassment and i just assume
that you uh folks reached out for
comments since the article is about me
and i
i must have not received it so um no one
else was answering this was the number
listed that i could find
okay uh one second steven let me uh pull
up the article here okay
thank you so much jessica i'm sorry to
bother you on this line i just was was
looking for a contact
okay thank you okay so this is out of
our australia bureau
last week so i can't because of the time
difference i can't immediately get in
touch with the australia writer or
editor
but um to confirm whether you did or did
not get an email
um if you weren't contacted i apologize
about that if you were i'm sorry that
you missed that
okay but i i would like to give you
now so i can take a note of it and then
reach out to our australia team to get
some back story here
sure i i appreciate that yeah i have
well i have a couple of questions
because i did look at your corrections
policy and it says that uh
uh grammar spelling style errors will be
corrected in the text if the error is
factual the correction will include an
editor's acknowledgement
at the bottom of the story and i assume
again it's because there was no request
for comment but there are some
really glaring uh verifiable factual
inaccuracies
uh here which i'd like to address those
first if we can
well i would like to actually record
this so i could get all of it absolutely
but i don't have
well i i don't i'm like i said i'm not
even in
i'm off today that's fine i don't have a
computer
with me or a recorder so you need to um
i can record this for you and send you
the file if you would like
no that's okay you just need to give me
a second to take notes here okay
thank you i'm sorry to bother you on
your day off i do appreciate you being
accommodating
i just thought you need to give me a
minute here sure
have you tried to reach anyone else at
nashville today stephen i left a
voicemail for annie
colbert okay yeah she's our executive
editor
um all right why don't we try and take
some notes here okay
sorry i uh i'm interested
i just got here with last night so i
need to you know set up here um
no i appreciate it all right let me take
some notes
sure well okay so to address kind of
just a couple of factual inaccuracies
here because
obviously my reputation matters when
it's a headline at
one of the biggest tech websites you
know you can imagine how that's
troubling um
in the article it says that uh
specifically crowder has stopped selling
t-shirts that say
carlos is a well pinky promising youtube
he'll never do it again
um i've never i've never had a t-shirt
that says that i've never had a t-shirt
even close to that i've never had a
t-shirt featuring that person
period none of that is true and i also
never
sorry i'm sorry i want to write this
down i've never had a t-shirt featuring
that person
and i've never had a t-shirt like that
yes
and uh what t-shirt do you think was the
reporter confusing this with
i i don't know you'd have to ask the
reporter because it's put directly in
quotes
but it's not even an idea that i had
until i read your reporter's suggestion
okay
jesus all right so you've never
had a t-shirt feature in that person
you've never had a t-shirt like that
what other inaccuracies do
you like to uh well you know so one is
and this kind of gets into the
almost a legal realm because i use the
terms that i made false allegations
against black lives matter
with no substantiation i just this is
where i guess i'd have to talk with the
author
no idea what that means what false
allegations i mean i know we disagree
politically
it's one thing to say that we disagree
politically it's another thing that said
he made false allegations um
i can tell you that i've never done that
uh but again it's tough when there's no
accountability or substantiation from
the
mashable reporters it's just listed
video making false allegations
we don't have a link to that video has
that video been removed
no i don't even know what video which
are you
are you reading a portion specifically
carter's channel is still spreading
harmful congruent conspiracy theories
and policy claiming that
black lives matter is a terrorist
organization of course
okay so no that's i was looking at a
different one but that one too i guess
it's
it's it's there a couple of times um
that would be another question harmful
coronavirus conspiracy theories
like what i've never peddled in any
conspiracy theory regarding the
coronavirus i've i've openly
i
do you believe they're conspiracies no
do you believe do you have theories that
you are spreading or i should say
sharing
that aren't necessarily scientifically
substantiated no not at all
we've only talked about the actual death
rates the availability of testing
and even while the surgeon general was
saying was advising americans not to
wear masks we had a sponsorship with a
company that retooled
their factory to make masks and i was
saying listen if you think that you may
be sick it's a good idea to wear a mask
so i was advocating for masks back when
the cdc and surgeon general
were saying you don't need masks so i
want to be really clear like i'm not an
anti-mask
anti the virus is a real thing right i
don't believe that it's something that
was created as some kind of a
biochemical weapon or some crazy
conspiracy by george soros
uh i believe that the numbers have been
grossly exaggerated and we've talked
about how the new york times
listed an article that said 41 of all
deaths are nursing home deaths so we've
talked about the news from
a point of view where i believe when dr
burke says the numbers could be inflated
by 25 percent
that that's relevant um i believe that
when the imperial college of london said
it would be two point something million
dead with a death rate of up to four to
seven percent
i said i don't believe that that's
accurate um but we've never
ever peddled conspiracies or anything
that's anti-science as a matter of fact
it's probably the most substantiated
show with links to third-party sources
you can question me on my views of
coronavirus if you'd like to hear
and i would gladly answer them no i'm
just uh what i'm doing here
the questions i'm asking you are sure
not again but in response to what i'm
reading
here and a line guess or a line
somewhere between what you're saying
when i'm reading
yeah so i'm just trying to uh let me
let's
call it quick and dirty fast check while
i'm saying no no i i appreciate it and i
appreciate you doing the job that your
reporter didn't
well but
you know i'm trying to figure out
your videos repeatedly targeted for
years making disparaging comments about
the writer's sexuality and ethnicity
are you claiming that you never had a
video about gaza
no i never claimed that so i thought i
was i was only calling about factual
inaccuracies but no i don't i didn't
complain about that
i did i definitely did i i definitely
did i did i did many videos uh uh
rebutting vox
he was there representative at vox for a
long time so we have videos that also
have gone
after factual inaccuracies and
unscientific videos
from vox um and many of them featured uh
carlos
so i obviously that's the reason for
this which mashable covered a long time
ago where they also didn't ask me for
comment
um we didn't violate any policies that's
pretty clear
the issue that i have are with the the
patently false
claims here like the t-shirt and then
other ones that you know just sort of
you know listen this is a frustration
working in media and trying to keep
myself accountable when someone says
false allegations against black lives
matter uh anti-coronavirus
or harmful coronavirus conspiracy
theories
what does that mean and you know why
isn't there a link because if i've done
it the easiest thing in the world would
be just to provide some proof of it
i'm curious obviously
but sure why
uh it was so wildly
reported over a year ago that you were
selling these t-shirts what's uh
what's your take on why that story went
seriously global here it's all the way
out to cbc news or cbs news
that i was selling shirts let's say
carlos
i don't know maybe because of the the
journalistic standard uh from reporters
that we see it mashable
i know i'm saying i got i i hope they
have higher standards but it doesn't
sound like they do it can
i mean you can call the unnamed source
at youtube which is
another question that i have how did you
guys know about this before we ever
announced being remonetized but
no one no one we've never done it you
can ask youtube that's not a thing we
never had a shirt like that
never existed okay i understand you're
upset here can i ask you a question
again you don't have to put this on the
record or anything all of this is on the
record
you can use all of it so we're in any
capacity that your audience which i know
you cannot control your audience
but are you aware that your audience is
creating these features
no not at all what does that have to do
with you but that's not the claim in the
article obviously so
i mean yeah that's not the same in my
article and that's the correction i'm
willing to make if i can
fact-check it on my own independently
but um
i'm just trying to like well let me ask
you this would the correction be
steven has never stephen crowder has
never sold this t-shirt and youtube
confirmed it or would the fact check be
though stephen crowder has never sold
these t-shirts some of his fans would
which could not be less relevant if
we're practicing journalism
i would probably put an update
one i would need to call my or get in
touch with my australia bureau which
again got a major time difference there
and i need to confirm with their own
research whether or not they found
evidence of you selling those shirts
if not i want to corrupt usually we
consider
a national news source like cbs news to
be strong enough as first party
um without having to corroborate against
two or three sources nevertheless given
the situation that was speaking about
now i want to corroborate the
news and claim that your uh audience was
selling the shirt
and if that were to be the case okay i
would if
you were i would issue an update that
says we spoke to stephen crowder for a
comment
he says that he never sold any such
t-shirts and we cannot find no hold on a
second i don't want you to just ask me
call your youtube representative right
because you wrote this whole article
about me and youtube not steven crowder
says
the correction should be it was
confirmed that stephen crowder
never sold that shirt boom that's it
i don't know why anything else would
need to be included not i say you can
confirm
with your sources if i've ever sold it
i'm telling you i haven't
but i would gladly request that you uh
confirm with a third party
specifically the other party involved
here your unnamed source at youtube
because i don't want to be a he said she
said there's truth and there's
falsehoods right there are falsehoods
and there's
there is truth i've never sold that
shirt i am curious as to the cbs article
i've never seen it
who do they link where do they link to
um to substantiate their claim that i
sold these shirts
that's why i want to do additional
research on my own here okay
yeah i appreciate it i really do because
you can see my frustration right if
you're telling me cbs did that
and i hope you uh understand because
i've been out
i'm getting caught up here sure on the
site i've been off
um i can't you know we publish 40
something things a day when i'm on
vacation i can't
no no i understand
and my problem is not with you i
appreciate you
um
asking your questions and i appreciate
it my problem is not with you my problem
is with
obviously journalism as a whole because
you know listen obviously conservatives
don't trust a lot of media and if you're
saying well good enough for us is cbs
saying it and cbs says
well good enough for us is no source at
all you can see how that's a
never-ending problem right an incestuous
relationship where there's really no
corroboration no substantiation no
accountability
and it's all unnamed sources and then if
i call and i can't call every single
source and demand a correction and if i
call those sources and the correction is
nothing more than
well steven says he didn't do this but
some fans did
that really looks more so like your
publication is trying to save face
then simply correct the statement made
which was
categorically false i would say
it's a combination of correcting and
also explaining
why the mistake was made in the first
i think it's pretty helpful for readers
and given the nature of journalism
and everything you're speaking of and
such a wide readership i think a couple
to explain why
a correction or why a mistake was made
when it's not something as
simple as a typo and you know
but again that really depends on what i
can find uh
find
no no i understand i would request that
you call whoever it was i spoke with at
youtube because youtube has never
claimed that
the original sources that are cited here
have never claimed that so that's what's
so
odd right they cite these original
sources though some of them the original
sources are mashable
but um then they don't cite any links to
the claims which kind of can't be fact
checked i'll be honest
false claims of coronavirus or false
allegations against black lives matter
listen i'm not a fan of black lives
matter the organization and if people
would like to link to that video
great but i can understand that i can't
really call a journalist on that you
know mashable is an opinion
this is you know it's an opinion website
um but
when there are verifiably false claims i
don't really know that it benefits the
reader to say well there were some fans
somewhere who sold it
because that does the whole kind of
guilt by association a little bit i
think it's more beneficial to the writer
to excuse away um what is at best
at best a sim simple factual uh
oversight
and at worst malicious intent which this
article seems
let's be honest rife with it's it's
effectively a hit piece
that's the question uh as i'm sitting
here
listening to you but also looking online
did your what is your involvement with
your shop how
directly do you manage it or do you work
with something like staff commerce or do
you outsource stuff
no we just have a lot of crowdershop.com
right and do you personally manage that
or anything you've got a staff or
yeah we have a staff but yeah what's on
there i sell
okay so was there any t-shirt previously
about
on that no
none
all right so the imaginary studies here
are the
t-shirts the
uh you're taking primary issue here with
the t-shirt what other corrections well
that i just i would
i would be curious you know i can't
really reach the author but i'd be
curious as to what harmful coronavirus
conspiracies
um would be included and what false
allegations against black lives matter
i'd be
what false i've never made any false
allegations against black lives matter
i've made claims that perhaps your
author disagrees with
i've stated factual problems that i have
with black lives matter as an
organization that maybe she disagrees
with and that's kind of the trend that
we're seeing here right if this author
disagrees with
um the coverage that i provide on the
coronavirus
it's harmful conspiracies if she
disagrees with my views on black lives
matter the organization these are false
allegations
and then just flat out making something
up or or
not fact checking at all because it
suits i mean you know listen i mean we
both
understand that the real problem that
both left the left has with fox news and
rightfully so
and the right has with pretty much
anyone in traditional media not named
fox news
is that journalists don't include
information that
doesn't fit a narrative and in this case
considering that this is such a
monumental case right of youtube
changing policy
it would behoove people who label
themselves journalists
to get it at least close to right
um tweeted that black lives matter is a
domestic terrorist organization what did
you mean by that
so there's an entire video on that and i
cite their own charter their own
motivations and their own claims of
violence
do you understand
yes which do you
no that's not what it is that's not the
only way do you can you please define
terrorism for me and then i'll tell you
exactly what it is
the use of violence or force to
intimidate in order to achieve a
political or ideological end
i don't have a dictionary in front of me
but that's especially against the state
or public as a politically motivated
means of attack recording
whether or not lives matter
is attack or coercion um
i think it's pretty
fair to objectively
claim here that they are not attacking
or coercing they are not you know
i disagree with civilian population
i disagree as an organization they do
not
incite violence against yes yes they do
can i can i explain to you why can i
explain to you
600 million dollars in property damage
over 20 deaths
over 14 000 arrests and over 900 officer
casualties
would you like me to read from their
direct charter as well and the
justification of violence
listen you can send me a link to it i'm
sitting here taking notes on where you
are taking issues
sure and you're taking quotes here from
you on your points of contention
and then i need to reach out to
australia which i think they are
probably i don't know three in the
morning right now so i can't do that
which i'm sure you understand so rather
than arguing and that is my fault for
even getting into it
rather than arguing whether or not well
you just made a claim but you didn't
substantiate it
you just made a claim and didn't
substantiate it and i'm making a claim
and offering substantiation would you
like me to provide my
reasoning based on statistical analysis
and objectifiable verifiable data that
comes from police departments and the
black lives matter
their own charter organization and
founding members because they do
encourage violence
we are talking about an article that is
primarily about youtube you are
justified in reaching out here because
you are
mentioned in it but this is not i am the
title
this is an article about youtube policy
no this is an article about
me in the title i am the title of the
article
be like saying oliver twist mentions
oliver
this is family to become a productive
conversation so you can
much like the art okay go ahead and i
can reach out
reporters and figure out some backstory
here absolutely
continue to give me corrections that i
can write down quotes for sure
but i just again the issue is that you
just said objectively but you provided
you provided no objectivity so i think
that matters and that explains maybe how
these
issues go on without being corrected but
please do ask and i'll answer to the
best of my ability
uh without being unproductive no you
know what i'm not interested in asking
right now because we're not really at
that phase i need to write down
the issues you have with actual
you know inaccuracies so your issues are
that what do you consider what have i
expressed that is not an actual
inaccuracy
false allegations against black lives
matter substantiated what false
allegations have i made that is an
accuracy as well
the t-shirt was made up i get that you
have an opinion on black lives matter or
amanda yo
does but the t-shirt is entirely made up
and i would like to know one false
allegation i made against black lives
matter
now if you want to say that you disagree
with me saying that an organization that
has resulted in
600 million dollars in property damage
900 officer casualties the calling for
the disruption and destruction of the
nuclear family the calling for violence
in the suburbs if you would like to
argue that that is in fact not
indicative of using
violence as a coercion tool for
political end then i think that should
be included in the article
but it's not it just as i made false
allegations and
that's not true
jessica she hung up on you you white
supremacist
that's what happened i guess i guess i
lost jessica jessica cone
i'm sitting here writing down what
you're saying oh okay thank you
i have my speaker my keyboard i
think you'd hear me well i'm glad it's a
quiet keyboard
all right so black lives matter t-shirt
t-shirt anything else harmful
coronavirus conspiracies
i'd love to hear one anything else i can
add to this list
i'm just asking i'd like to hear one
anything i guess we
you know if you set up a call perhaps
with uh our conversation with amanda i
would love to
uh either host her and talk about it
because i understand that she is the one
who's made the claims not yourself
um but i would look down that's not
magical right now i'm just trying to
figure out
so you stand by the shirt down under and
i'm taking notes on what you're saying
right now
and i've been doing that now for 25
minutes is there anything
else you're taking issue with
specifically
yeah so you stand by mashable's false
allegations against black lives matter
the issue of the t-shirt and the harmful
coronavirus conspiracy theory
yes and you you you said you stand by
everything that is up on mashable right
now as the editor-in-chief
yeah i couldn't think they were
imperfect
that are in chief of mashable and it was
my job to stand by what you're doing
right now until i find a reason
otherwise i need to get some backstory
so you do stand okay that's fine if you
stand by it then that's fine that
changes the conversation
listen i need to find out that story
okay
if there's a correction or an update to
be made here i'm going to make a
correction or an update
but i need to get into that story and
then i would have one final question
and uh this is not about a false claim
but you know we spoke with
youtube about this for a long time and
they requested that we not discuss this
until it be
uh public so we didn't uh and mashable
uh released a story on this several days
before
so the only people who knew about the
remonetization were me and someone at
youtube
uh so i'm curious as to where that
information was procured
youtube call youtube called you
no i'm sorry you're saying that the
youtube
the the details about the youtube stuff
you're saying you spoke several days
like later
than when we posted the article yes it
was never announced and no one could
have possibly known
uh except for me and direct higher ups
at youtube so i'm curious how mashable
um got this story public before we were
even publicly remonetized
well i would say that if there are only
certain people who knew about it then we
probably
have a source that we're not going to
reveal okay yeah some someone at youtube
i would imagine
i i like i said i really don't know um
because this is a work in progress here
i would really appreciate it if you did
not tweet or put this on your channel
um since i'm trying to have a
conversation with you here
can i get your email sure it is
okay and because of the time zone issues
in the interest of getting some sort of
update on there is there a specific
comment
you would like me to take note of right
now i've got a
quote i've never had a t-shirt featuring
that person i've never had a t-shirt
like that
um i've never made allegations regarding
blm
um i was advocating for maps i believe
the virus is a real thing
i'm sure i was that i was advocating for
yeah oh yeah masks sorry i thought i
heard maps i was thinking well on a
second no that's that's dora
i'm just reading direct quotes from here
i was advocating for masks
i believe the virus is a real thing and
i believe that the numbers have been
grossly exaggerated
yeah i i believe the death uh the death
rates
have been and i that's and that's what
we've covered in quoting dr burks
um and the new york times so i believe
the new york times and dr burks i just
want to be clear about that these aren't
harmful false conspiracies these come
from the country's top medical
professionals and
though now of course my trust has been
eroded
america's most trustworthy news source
in the new york times
and above all i would just really like i
would just really like people like
amanda yo or
if it's matt if you stand by it mashable
to hold
these kinds of articles the same
standard that we do our content i get
that people disagree with it but
we constantly provide substantiation in
sources i will never
make a factual claim without a source
and then if we do and it's wrong then we
correct it
all right so here's what i'm going to do
today because i want to be able to
address this for you today
what i'm going to do right now is i'm
going to add an update to the story
okay and i'm going to include the
following quotes
okay i've never had a teacher featuring
that person or i've never had a t-shirt
like that
who said those things i've never made
false allegations regarding black lives
matter
i was advocating for mass i believe the
virus is a real thing and i believe that
the death rates have been grossly
exaggerated those numbers come from
america's top medical experts in the new
york times
that those three statements
address the t-shirt
whether or not the lm the bln
allegations
and they say they are not full and
that you are not spreading conspiracy
theories you are debating numbers
sure and you know what what would
honestly be best is considering that you
you link to uh
to other websites that don't
substantiate it you can link or include
the videos themselves where i've made
the claims about black lives matter i
would encourage you to watch them
see what they are and let people at
least see for themselves
so i can't really do that right now
because i want to get this update on
there immediately
in order to address the fact that we've
had this phone call immediately
and then later we give this some
time and get in touch with australia
we'll figure out the due diligence i'm
looking at those videos okay
okay well i just i mean whether you
whether they whether you agree with the
videos or not when it says steven
crowder is making false allegations
about black lives matter
why not just hyperlink to the video in
question
because then it'll be very clear right
if i'm making those alligator false
allegations
easiest thing in the world would be for
people to see it
right now because i can't sit and watch
all of your videos right now and
address this with an update in an
efficient and quick manner
okay i think you'd want that update
within the next 20 minutes as opposed to
me sifting through your youtube videos
and finding things to link to
am i correct in that regard how about
one link
and there are links to all kinds of
sites with notes as you've said yourself
no substantiation right links to sites
that provide no other links
how about a link to the direct content
in question i'm not asking you to look
through all the videos i'm simply asking
you to
link to the claim in question from your
author
in that article in that phrase just link
to the one that they're addressing in
the phrase
easiest thing in the world would prevent
you from a retraction or having to stand
by
junk science and claims from you just
link to it
right now i'm putting an update to
reflect that you and i have spoken on
the phone okay
who cares if we've spoken on the phone
we care if the article is accurate
and the article linked to the actual
video
listen it's my reporter's name okay and
what they got it right or not
i do have an obligation to make sure
that if i say they got it wrong i need
to make sure that i am
100 certain they got it wrong what does
that have to do with linking to the
video she's addressing i don't
understand that if she's addressing the
video it would be plain to see that i
got it wrong she brought up the video
you're not you're not throwing her under
the bus by going oh we should probably
link to the video where you claim
for example if you if there's a claim
stephen crowder murdered a puppy in his
black lives matter video and there's no
link to the video and i say hey i didn't
murder a puppy
just link to the video that's puppy
murderless
i think it's relevant
change my mind black lives matter is a
domestic terrorist organization changed
my mind all right i'll check it out
thank you yeah i i don't you know you
don't need to rush to
get this up that we spoke if you'd like
to that's great what's more important to
me is that there's a rush to correct the
factual inaccuracies in the article and
i understand you can't do that right now
um but if you give me a time frame on
that and i'll just look for it you don't
you don't need to get this on the
article right away but i appreciate you
wanting to
what about this fan i'm like i am
traveling sure
i cannot i'm trying to update something
now because i don't know how long it's
going to take me to get
in touch with australia sure all right
i'm like unlike other people i have
answered my phone to speak with you
thank you i do appreciate that with my
staff because again
i'm not working i'm working now but i'm
not managing the site today
i i appreciate that i was with that in
mind
out of courtesy if you were not
contacted for comment
then the correct thing to do without
even having to research and get that
story
the correct thing to do would be if
nothing else
certainly to add an update with your
comment now
because your comments were not included
in the first place correct
i appreciate that yeah it's i'm just i'm
just saying i don't want you to think on
your day off
i am not sure i'm not saying that is the
only way to address it
that is the first thing i can do right
now yes to address something that went
up five days ago
sure and what what i am just saying just
can i just
right now just one moment yes one moment
what i'm saying i i think you're seeing
a conflict with us and what i'm saying
is
hey i'm not going to be upset if you
have to take a little while to let
people know that we we spoke i i
you don't i it's your day off you don't
have to get this up in the next 20
minutes
so i won't give you i won't give anyone
any flack for that you're absolutely
coming in to pinch hit
what i'm saying is i understand it i
appreciate it
if within the next call it we can figure
time from
12 to 24 hours it's not corrected
factually
that's where i'll have a problem so i
don't want you ruining your time off to
get it up in 20 minutes
but let's set a time frame my job is my
job so i don't care about taking my time
off what i care about
is my inability right now to really
settle in at my computer and start
digging in with my staff
sure okay okay not about whether or not
i have vacation i don't give a [ __ ] my
job is my job
what i'm talking about is the physical
inability to sit down and really get
into this right now and clearly this is
something that merits
actual disruption with my team right
across time zone
uh 24 hours i cannot promise you that
because
i don't i it doesn't even matter what
i've got on my schedule tomorrow
the point is i don't i'm not able to
my life as the ics a lot of meetings
let's be honest here
and please don't vote beyond that or
anything but getting in touch with
people
is not like an immediate overnight [ __ ]
or immediate five-minute thing
so what i will tell you is that i would
like to get that update on there
because i want to address this in some
capacity
on the off chance that i can't get in
touch
with australia in under 24 hours
okay well then i i appreciate you being
a time frame i don't want to promise you
a time frame stephen
what i want to promise you is that i
will get back to you okay well i i
appreciate it
sorry i'm in the meantime okay
okay well i appreciate you being
accommodating um
i i really do and i'm sorry that this
kind of fell in your lap i appreciate
that you answered your phone
sounds seem like the the problem is more
so your staff i will say
this because this this is important um
if i had a member of my
staff who directly made a factually
inaccurate statement
with no corroboration whatsoever and i
could not reach them for within 24 hours
to correct it immediately
i would fire them and i'm a late night
host comedian
so i'm hoping it can be done within 24
hours
okay do your best that's all i ask i
appreciate it jessica thank you very
i would appreciate much taking this
conversation off the record okay
i can't promise it but i appreciate it
you have a good day
that conversation was ending night she
couldn't promise you anything
but you gotta promise her hey keep the
shelter up
[ __ ] you lady
hey if you enjoyed this show uh
subscriber hit the notification
i'm cov it's cold in here so i'm
covering i'm covering my nips
hit all notifications on the
notification bell because uh apparently
notification
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
look at their video what they're playing
in boxes is that what's happening
quarterback here
their videos playing in boxes you should
click one of them
maybe one of them's a mystery box
could cut glass with these things